looking for a great name for your new
business here's a tip if you'd like to
avoid litigation stay away from Will
Ferrell movies the company behind Ricky
Bobby sports saloon and restaurant in
Fort Worth Texas was sued by Sony
Pictures on March 6 for trademark
infringement according to the complaint
the restaurant is based on the Will
Ferrell movie Talladega Nights The
Ballad of Ricky Bobby my red hot smokin
wife Carly the restaurant features
scantily clad waitresses called smokin
Heidi's has a Chevrolet Monte Carlo
racecar that's nearly identical to the
one Farrell drove in the movie has a
sign with part of Ricky Bobby's mantra
your lap trademark not to use you
outside through the Ricky Bobby and has
drinks like coming at you like a spider
monkey that reference lines from the
movie Ritz Cabaret international the
publicly traded corporation behind the
Ricky Bobby restaurant also runs topless
nightclubs has more than 1200 employees
and had more than 112 million dollars in
revenue last year so can they start a
restaurant that looks a whole lot like a
Talladega Nights theme restaurant
without permission likelihood of
confusion is often the key legal
question in trademark infringement if
it's possible that consumers will be
confused about who is behind Ricky Bobby
the court is likely to find for Sony
rick's cabaret international has yet to
respond to the complaint but probably
best to think twice before naming your
new business after anchorman The Legend
of Ron Burgundy you stay classy San
Diego